denise world market center the
well-known exhibition venue
is adding to its location quite
significantly there was a ribbon-cutting
ceremony for the new area
which could entice more manufacturers to
come to our area and showcase their
products
sasha loftus attended the event she
joins us live downtown with all
the details hi sasha
good evening kirsten we are actually
inside the expert world market center
this brand new
expansion it's really just pretty large
and beautiful
as you can see and many say it is a
really a sign of rebound for our local
trade industry
now the expo at world market center will
provide 315
000 square feet of space for exhibitions
here in downtown las vegas
the new show area will accommodate up to
1 000 booths
for furniture and home decor exhibitors
to really showcase their products here
locally
a few familiar faces we're here to
unveil this new space
including las vegas mayor carolyn
goodman who spoke on the real excitement
of today
the statement for us to have this
fabulous
expo here what it means to all those who
come into town
the closeness of everything in the heart
of the city besides
being the place where all roads come
together
makes it absolutely nirvana
there was a pretty decent crowd here all
masked and socially distanced of course
to witness this milestone you can hear
them clapping there
now back out here live the expo also
features a new lobby
a shuttle bus depot and new food options
again to really further entice those
vendors to head out here
and showcase their products locally and
really expand downtown and help that
local trade show industry rebound
reporting live in downtown las vegas
tonight social office
8 news now